if I could rusev redesign your world but
what I do well everybody I would start
to develop the concept of democratic
accountability my name is John Williams
I was a member of parliament in Canada
for 15 years and the chairman of the
public accounts there I realized that if
we are going to have government serve
the people that people have to have the
capacity all the government's
accountable the world bank tells us that
1.5 billion people around the world a
destitute and after world is poor yet I
haven't found anybody that ever voted
for poverty so why are the poor and why
are the destitute is because they do not
have the capacity to hold a government
accountable for the services that they
expected when they voted for the
government's therefore we have to build
there's democratic accountability where
by governments are accountable to the
people not to the international
financial institutions and not the
united nations are not to some other
organization to the people whom they
were elected to serve unfortunately when
they got into power they write the rules
to serve themselves and keep themselves
in power and by doing so they can steal
the cash with impunity in worst cases of
riding a comer do citizens so they can
stay apart that has to choose so if i
were to redesign the world i would put
two people and charged my account
ability of the government and that way
the government would know if they don't
serve the people people find somebody
else and they're out of office or maybe
jail thank